Amy
hey I thought I missed you Hey Jake
amazing assignment I have to admit
I'm a little jealous really well if you
want I could help you get fired I'm
really good at it yeah
this is real this is happening
look um
I don't want to be a jerk I know
you're dating Teddy and it's going
really well it's just what's going on
I don't know what's going to happen on
this assignment and if something bad
goes down I think I'd be pissed at
myself if I didn't say this
ah
I kind of wish something
could happen between us
romantic styles
and I know it can't because you're with
Teddy and I'm going undercover and
that's just how it is but
anyway we're
not supposed to have any contact so I
should go America needs me
bye
[Music]
a whole hour till we testify hey donut
holes don't mind if I do oh
fish
fish Donuts boil what is wrong with you
it's takoyaki I'm drowning my sorrows
and octopus balls I've been online
dating it's a total disaster I've only
had one match and it was a pretty
obvious catfish situation my name
Jennifer you gave me Social Security oh
Jennifer now I see that as a positive
story out of all the identities he could
have stolen he chose yours and you want
to know why because I posted my annual
income because you posted your annual
income you excuse me it's the
takoyaki yeah from senka right down the
street oh I love that place the chef
lets me take octopus Hearts home for my
dogs oh lucky how many dogs you have oh
too many three that's how many I have oh
all right wait a quick question how do
you keep them off the bed I gave up I
sleep on the floor me too it's better
for your back
wow well nice meeting you
completely what are you doing she's
walking away I got nervous she eats
octopus balls and she sleeps on the
floor she's the perfect woman God wait
sorry I was aiming at somebody else but
now that I have your attention Charles
he was saying he had a terrible criminal
he probably saved the world do you want
to have a takiyaki at the on the bench
over there
I was hoping he'd ask
that work here is done oh still fish oh
God hey
where'd she go you guys were hitting it
off I half expected to see you sitting
in her lap by now she is amazing her
palette is wide and deep gross and at
one point when she wasn't looking I
snuck a wolf of her hair of course she
did she uses one of my top three
shampoos to his coconut extra lather
sounds good boy did you get her number
oh we lost track of time she had to go
back into court when she's done I'm
gonna ask her out oh okay okay so what's
the plan going straight from here to the
spa couples massage okay seems a little
intense but given how your other
weirdness lined up I say go for it oh
there she comes whoa okay how do I look
you look great I've got a good feeling
about this
Genevieve I know we just met and I don't
want to be too forward Charles sometimes
you just get a feeling about a person
Charles I got that feeling about you I
like you Charles look down tonight oh
shoot they just gave me 10 years in
prison
[Music]
and say no
that's it I gotta completely disappear
it's nothing for me here and what if
Rosa gets caught in the crossfire no no
no listen we're gonna protect you guys
and we're gonna take these guys down
right Sarge absolutely no no no don't
you see right now they think I'm dead
this is my only chance to get away safe
Jake
I need you to tell Rosa that I love her
okay do that for me also tell her this
oh
oh my
ew
that is very graphic Adrian
got it I don't think I can say any of
that to Rosa and also you can't leave
without saying goodbye to her you owe
her that much hey man how'd it go last
night search cool later you know oh
so you haven't seen him huh no
I figured he'd just passed out of your
place or something why what's going on
let's go for a walk
he wanted me to tell you that he loves
you is that it did he say anything else
may the Lord be with you
Adrian
oh my God
oh
scared me I thought you left
I did
I was burning my fingerprints off in a
gas station bathroom when I thought
about what Jake said
I couldn't leave without seeing one last
time
I want to lick your whole body clean
like a kitty cat yeah I'm gonna give you
two a little space
I have to go
but I'll be back for you oh wait
and while I'm waiting I will find that
FBI agent and I will rip his head off
with my bare hands that is the sweetest
thing anybody's ever said to me I love
you I love you
you okay yeah
it will be
I watched you guys kiss I didn't know
where to look all right let's go inside
okay
we wanted to apologize and if you want
to gloat about how you outsmarted us go
ahead we deserve it I won't be doing any
gloating I mean I did last night I went
home and had a drink to toast to your
humiliation but it didn't feel right
because I had no one to toast with I
want to share my Glee I had won but
I was alone
and I realized this is exactly what I'm
doing to Kevin trying to win therapy and
it hit me I care so much about winning
and I've lost everything
tell Kevin how you feel
you feel this is the real world time
here I go relationships and unsatisfying
ways every day
they don't run to each other in the rain
Kevin
Raymond am I too late too late my friend
saw your dating profile in your photo
without color stays I thought I'd lost
you will never lose me
I'll do anything to keep you I'll
compromise on everything the work the
Nancy Myers never fails
now that we're doing it it feels kind of
weird to be staring at your friends
while they kiss are you kidding it's
beautiful
[Music]
I love you
hello Jacob Hames
what are you doing here why aren't you
out looking for the belt you and I both
know the belt never left the precinct I
don't know that nobody knows that I kept
thinking how did anyone swap my key and
then it hit me they didn't they swapped
the safe one of the handmaids I'm
assuming fake Charles took my safe and
then of Amy deposited a look-alike
where did you give fake Charles so he'd
help you nothing in fact he gave me
something the power of Financial Freedom
I invested in a pyramid scheme it's no
time to go into it right now okay
so while we all tried to figure out who
had the real key fake Charles broke into
the safe removed the tracker and let
Terry and the whole squad on a wild
goose chase my only question is which
box is the belt in wow good luck
figuring it out because the clock is
Tick Tick tocking it's that one no the
dust pattern on top doesn't match its
neighbors
you see Jake I'm always gonna be one
step ahead of you you've lost the
ability to surprise me you just plain
boring again weird take on our very
loving relationship and it's midnight so
I guess I'm an amazing human slash
genius yeah
although
you might want to read the inscription
on that there built why oh no what does
it say
Amy Santiago will you marry me
surprise
I'm so confused I don't know what's
happening right now I'm so confused I
don't know what's happening right now
title your sex tape
oh shaking I'm definitely gonna cry
titled your sex tape wait is this really
happening is this part of the heist if
this is part of the heist I will dump
you so hard no please hey it's like it's
really happening okay it's not part of
the heist I promise this is
you are I love how beautiful you are I
love your face and I love your butt I
should have written this down first no
no it's okay go on I love how much you
pretend to like die hard I like the
second one you don't have to okay yeah
you're kind and you're funny and you're
the best person I know and
the best detective
also for reals I love your butt I love
yours too gross
Amy Santiago
will you marry me
Jake Peralta I will marry you
I love you so much hey it's your goes
this little Escape so that ought
to teach
you just